in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Ryan
and the Diana are with us hey guys how
are you
we're great Dave welcome welcome Patti
to be here we're excited to have you
where are you from
we're from Springfield Oregon awesome
very cool welcome to Nashville it's a
bit of a haul yep
so you're here to do your debt-free
scream how much of you paid off we've
paid off one hundred ninety five
thousand one hundred forty dollars and
fifty cents I love that way to go you to
awesomeness and how long did that take
you just like a marathon it took twenty
six months just over twenty six months
that's incredible well done what do you
guys make right now we're making about a
hundred and fifty thousand and what you
start out this process about a hundred
thousand but it are we peaked at a two
hundred and eight thousand whoa with
extra jobs and lots of overtime
craziness okay yes it's going bananas
and so you're gonna back it back down
and breathe again exactly very cool very
cool what do you guys do for a living
I'm a PA mm-hmm
and I'm a personal banker at first tech
/ Federal Credit Union very cool good
for you guys excellent so what kind of
debt is this a PA I'm guessing a little
student loan I like to collect master's
degrees I have an MBA and decided that
medicine was really my true passion and
so I went back to school and got a
second master's in physician assistant
studies Wow so it was all student loans
neither white almost we had a little
consumer debt in there
one hundred and seventy nine thousand in
student loans and the rest was credit
cards okay so did you just graduate
Dianna's that what started this or
what's the story what happened 26 months
ago okay well basically I like many
other people out there thought if we
just get through school and get the
good-paying jobs that all our financial
problems would be solved but that wasn't
the case we knew about you a long time
ago and we just figured well we'll get
to that later and yeah so when I
graduated
we had been tired of going without and
so we
did something like the Taj Mahal which
is something you said you and Sharon did
a long time ago and we just lived it up
and thought you know we're making good
money we can just you know use our good
income to pay off the debt and then we
realized about nine months later that
our debt hadn't budged and actually we
were in more debt than what we started
yeah we were making eighteen hundred
dollar minimum payments and not watching
that needle move at all so it's a long
story but we went on a road trip to Zion
and we had absolutely nothing to listen
to you but your podcasts I'd never
listened to your podcast before but Ryan
had and so hours and hours of listening
to you and the debt-free screams and
something clicked in me and I realized
yes this is it we need to do this now so
that's what it flipped the switch for us
so Ryan this was your this was your
sneak attack turn on the firehose of
Dave Ramsey now water boarding there was
nothing else to listen to it was a last
resort she got elated everything else
you sneaky thing you die at what point
did you realize he had done this to you
I think it was a god thing the timing
was just right yeah very cool all
kidding aside that's wonderful I'm
haunted I appreciate it so you came home
from the road trip and what was the
first thing you did so we actually were
living in Arizona at that point just
briefly and we decided we were gonna go
back to Oregon and we made a choice to
live in my mom's basement Thank You
georgette yes so have you left yet yes
she said thank you yes so yeah we we
decided we were gonna get on a plan we
were gonna live on beans and rice sweet
chili homemade vegetarian chili that we
ate every day for two years
both of us worked our jobs and then I it
took me about six months but I finally
found a second job which was pretty
lucrative working at an urgent care on
weekends and I'm just gonna do a side
note we were living in Salem at the time
and I drove an hour to Springfield
Monday through Thursday then I drove an
hour north to Portland to work on the
weekends Wow yeah so she was sacrificing
her weekends working a normal job plus
another job in an hour each way
community thought she was well into yeah
yes there were times where I worked
seven days a week most the time it was
six but I had days where I just had the
opportunity and just kept going and I
think I did a stint of twenty days in a
row yeah Wow yeah very cool very cool
you guys are incredible when you get
that intense though you move the needle
exactly exactly opposite of feeling like
you're in the retinol wheel now you're
really getting traction
exactly it starts whaling on that thing
and you move almost $200,000 in just a
little over two years
that's exciting oh man I mean you you're
knocking down seven eight grand a month
and dead in this process more yeah yeah
we we made we made them some months we
made payments of over like $10,000 we've
got so excited yeah every time we got to
move that lead needle we we toasted to
to that and we just celebrated it and we
got so excited and we just people around
us were really worried about how intense
we were they were concerned about how we
were quote overdoing it and we tried to
let him know you know this is so when
you have to do an intervention you've
joined a cult they were joking about
doing an intervention no but but now now
how do I like you now that's right yeah
now who needs an intervention now we get
to now spend a lot more time with our
friends and family yeah and we're just
really appreciative of that that's
excellent you guys are incredible that
is fabulous okay so obviously you
increase your hours you've increased
your income and you did this with great
focused intensity what other things
would you tell people the secret to
getting out of debt
well they've we have lots of secrets but
I'm just a few of them and we really
kept the numbers right in front of us
I made an excel pie chart and we visited
that often and every time we made a
payment we saw that thing move we
celebrated another thing is like she
said we made some deep sacrifices with
her we were we had to be willing to make
those deep sacrifices the chili the two
years in the basement and giving up
weekends and the third thing is we
really had to keep a hope in a vision of
what being debt-free was gonna look like
did we want to go out into the
marketplace and have to earn that
eighteen hundred dollars a minimum
payments or did we want to have that
time with our future family and each
other what do you think Diana yeah so
secrets also we did what you recommend
and we identified our budget Buster's so
for us we love food and wine and I like
to go get my nails done inherited and
all that so we just identified those
weaknesses and made plans to overcome
that so I would I took myself off all
these email lists and I stayed offline
you know I'd like to online shopping so
I would just say removing the temptation
mmm is a secret that's good
yeah yeah that's good most of all though
we want to thank God because he is the
one that sustained us and gave us the
endurance to get through when we first
started this process it was very painful
and I was praying and I felt like the
Lord told me watch me work and so I did
I watched I watched him sustain us I
watched him give us opportunities to
work we always wanted to get a windfall
you know when one of your contests or
something but the Lord blessed us with
more and more opportunities to work and
he gave us the strength to remain strong
and it's right endure and our
relationship actually made it through so
we give him all the glory every time
you're looking for a windfall there was
that mirror you were the windfall right
yeah you were you're the secret sauce we
had to keep reminding each other of what
our relationship looked like before we
did this thing because we were real
happy before and and we knew that we
would be again
when the quality of life increased again
yeah absolutely you know well how's your
feel great paid off our last payment
exactly three months ago today and life
has just been so good ever since then
yeah well congratulations you two
you're a crow we say one more thing
though very quick well I don't know it's
gonna be quick we went to Italy right
before our debt free we celebrated with
a Europe trip three weeks all right
count it down let's hear your debt free
scream three two one
love it love it well Don you too well
done man that's fabulous this is the
Dave Ramsey show hey you guys Rachael
Cruz here hope you are enjoying the Dave
Ramsey show if you didn't know I
actually have my own YouTube channel so
I had two videos twice a week on life
and money so you can click the subscribe
button to subscribe to my channel and if
you want to check out our video right
now check out the video on how to make a
budget